[Musique]
on va parler d'une opération formidable
un concours auquel vous pouvez vous
inscrire entre le 26 janvier et le 26
février c'est la recette du meilleur
Yolin et pour en parler bah l'inventeur
du Yolin Laurent trochin bonjour bonjour
Patrice euh vous êtes vous êtes un chef
chef étoilé reconnu de de restaurant qui
s'appelle numéro 3 qui est au trembler
sur moldre euh mais c'est on va pas
parler de de vous précisément mais de
votre invention si je peux dire qui
s'appelle le Yolin le Yolin alors le
Yolin euh c'est une sorte d'acronyme
enfin voilà hein faut dire ça i grec
comme Eveline yeline tout à fait oui
voilà ouais o pour olympique et l pour
le local voilà et le i n pour inclusif
voilà c'est ça inclus et et comme vous
êtes je disais un grand chef un chef
reconnu bah on va parler de de de ce
qu'on mange etine ça se mange alors
l'idée je je le résume et puis vous
allez préciser après euh c'est de partir
bah de quelque chose que tout le monde
peut faire ouais tout à fait ouais c'est
ça c'estd la patte euh d'une quiche
loride voilà l'appareil l'appareil d'une
quiche sans pâte justement voilà c'est
encore c'est encore plus simpleâ
c'est-à-dire des œufs des œufs du lait
et de la farine donc quand on dit farine
on s'arrête pas la farine de blé on va
en parler mais mais il y a tout style de
farine ouais voilà à partir de euh ce
comment vous appelez ça on appelle ça un
appareil voilà on appelle ça un
appareil une base voilà un appareil une
base pareil euh et ben il va falloir que
les gens qui participent à ce concours
parce que c'est un concours on va en
parler ajoute trois produits qu'on peut
trouver dans les ivelines voilà au
minimum trois produits au minimum trois
produits des ivelines et quand on parle
de produits des ivelines c'est-à-dire ça
peut être évidemment des produits de la
terre des produits de l'élevage mais ça
peut être des produits venant de tout
commerçant des métiers de bouche des
hiblines c'està-dire un épicier un
boucher un poissonnier un fromager un
cabiste aussi voilà et Cera tout à fait
oui l'imagination est tout pouvoir
c'estàdire que à partir de de cet
appareil simple on peut faire on peut
inventer ce qu'on veut euh il y a je
crois 259 vill et villages dans les
ivelines c'est ça c'est ça tout à fait
ouais ouai ouais sur tout le département
qui est très très grand on a 259
communes alors bah dans toutes les
communes euh on espère que des gens vont
s'inscrire vont participer vont proposer
leur recette il y aura donc bah si on
prend un gagnant par ville et par
village il y aura donc 259 gagnants
voilà il y aura 259 gagnants donc c'est
un peu particulier pour un pour un
concours hein c'est c'est inédit hein de
toute façon pour faire gagner euh une
personne par par ville et village mais
euh c'est un challenge qu'on s'est lancé
et euh et donc on a on a été bien
accueilli évidemment par par les mairies
hein pour pour communiquer sur ça
commenc à communiquer bien sû et alors
euh ces 259 gagnant ben il va avoir la
la la joie le plaisir l'honneur d'être
publié dans un livre c'est ça voilà un
livre de recette hein euh qui va
paraître le 26 juin donc aussi un mois
avant les gios juste avant lesà livre
complet de recett de Yolin mais pas que
c'est-à-dire que on aura évidemment une
page par commune avec l'adresse de la
commune les informations sur la commune
et la recette de Yolin avec
évidemment le nom de de la personne qui
et surtout surtout les bonnes adresses
des commerçants des Ilin qui seront
situés sur la page du gagnant bien sûr
alors justement vous avez
euh un site auquel je renvoie tous les
gens qui qui qui s'intéressent yolin.fr
he c'est ça tout à fait ouai ouais donc
très simple très simple à trouver et
dans ce site il y a il y a en effet une
chose formidable c'est que il y a toute
la liste euh des des producteurs euh des
des métiers de bouche aussi enfin euh
dans lesquels on peut trouver et des
produits au fond qu'on peut trouver dans
les evvelines et ce qui est assez fraent
c'est qu'on trouve de tout oui on trouve
de tout donc cette base de données
aujourd'hui on est à peu près à 300 300
adresses mais il en manque encore
énormément euh donc on invite évidemment
tous les acteurs des métiers de bouche
comme je dis de de l'éleveur au aux
commerçants à s'inscrire c'est gratuit
c'est entièrement gratuit et ils sont
référencés sur le site de Yolin du Yolin
donc ça permet aussi je veux dire à aux
touristes aux gens des Yvelines de de
savoir ce qu'il y a à côté de chez eux
et aussi ça aide pour faire ce concours
puisqu'on va trouver aussi des des
éléments des alimie de de de tel produit
je sais que je peux aller dans une ferme
dans chez un che chez
un marchand enfin voilà il il y a les
adresses qui sont qui sont absolument
formidables alors là on a euh en photo
des recettes qui ont déjà été un peu
fabriqué qui qui sont un peu des
exemples de ce qu'on pourrait faire avec
le Yolin voà sachant qu'on part de zéro
hein donc quand on dit Yolin aujourd'hui
personne ne connait Yolin voilà donc on
démarre voilà c'est parti maintenant on
l'annonce à partir de demain donc le
site est ouvert et et donc oui on peut
trouver sur le site voilà des exemples
de ouais bien sûr on a mis des photos on
a mis vidé et et donc comme ça pour
montrer que le Yolin c'est c'est pas non
plus on s'arrête pas à un seul dressage
on va parler en professionnel à un seul
dressage c'està-dire que il peut être
servi en assiette c'està-dire en petite
mise en bouche là par exemple en gros
savez alors écoutez oui oui alors on en
a fait tellement alors c'est pour ça que
le Yolin déjà quand on parle de la base
des œufs de la farine et du lait déjà il
y a les dosages donc ça veut dire est-ce
que vous mettez du jaune d'œuf un uf
jaune d'œuf est-ce que vous mettez
est-ce que vous montez les blancs est-ce
que vous allez mettre de la farine de
maïs de la farine de de blé de la farine
de poisiche et cetera et cetera il y a
tellement de choses dans les zvelines
après le lait comment vous allez doser
le lait donc déjà cette base là c'est
pour ça quand je dis il y a 1500000
habitants des zvines il peut y avoir
plus d'00000 recettes donc déjà cette
base elle peut varier et après ce qu'on
va mettre dedans et ben là je pense que
on avait fait c'était au beau jour on
avait fait quelque chose avec euh avec
de la courgette avec des tomates dedans
voilà et on avait mis des bons œufs de
ferme c'est pour ça que l'appareil est
bien jaune aussi voilà et d'ailleurs on
voit aussi comment on peut battre enfin
fabriquer un peu le le ouais voilà il y
a une petite vidéo alors on a fait on a
fait des vidéos très simples c'est
vraiment un conours c'est vraiment un
concours qui s'adresse à à à à tout le
monde ENF compris ouais voilà et qu'on
sache ou pas faire la cuisine ou voilà
et c'est vraiment quelque chose de très
mélanger un œuf avec de la farine du
lait y ajouter des éléments c'est c'est
c'est c'est très simple et la cuisson
ben c'est au four dans les 160 165°gr ça
après je laisse chacun faire comme il
veut sil ve quelque chose vous donnez
quand même des conseil c'est ça qui on
donne des conseils bien sûr c'est
important parce que on a chacun des des
niveaux de cuisine différents donc le
but de de de de ce concours il faut
l'appeler concours parce que ça reste un
concours avec des lots à gagner c'est
vraiment de de faire participer un
maximum de personnes de montrer que
c'est très simple euh et et pour donner
envie aux gens de le faire chez eux et
après donner aussi envie aux
restaurateurs de le faire dans les
restaurants mais voilà on voulait
quelque chose quand même qui qui rentre
dans les foyers et de montrer que c'est
accessible à tous accessible à tous et
quand je disais oui c'est ça les enfants
c'est vrai que si si euh participer en
famille ça peut être ça peut être très
festif en plus hein voilà bien bien sûr
parce que l'originalité va compter dans
l' Yolin hein euh mais euh et on sait
que les enfants manquent pas
d'imagination hein peut-être quelquefois
débordante mais il manque pas
d'imagination donc et Ben et puis
mélanger de la farine et des œufs ça s'
plaît à à tout le monde et à tout enfant
donc bien sûr ou est-ce que vousmême
mais alors vous avez essayé quelques
quelques recettes puisque sur le site on
voit des des photos de de de de
résultats très différents voilà par
exemple dressage c'est autre chose que
que dans la siette voà donc là en fait
c'est un Yolin qui a été cuit dans un
moule dans dans un moule et qui a été
démoulé ensuite et qui a été repassé au
four pour qu'il y ait un petit
croustillant sur le côté donc en fait ça
c'est une bouchée donc c'est pour
montrer que le Yolin donc cette base
donc comme on disait d'appareil à quiche
peut être servi en restaurant peut être
mangé dans une assiette avec la cuillère
mais peut aussi être
manger comme ça emboucher voilà c'est
vraiment c'est c'est vraiment
l'important là-dedans dans dans dans ce
Yolin c'est de dire voilà on a un
produit où on a au moins TR trois
produits identifiés desid base simple et
après trabilité qui est important voilà
ou voilà est-ce que est-ce que vous même
comme ça vous
amusant pas que vous amuser parce que
vousz travaillé aussi mais en créant des
yolins parfois vous êtes surpris ouais
tout à fait parce
que et puis alors on peut en faire comme
végétarien on va dire au poisson à la
viande et et et même le
végétarien on fait des mélanges alors on
connaît ces mélanges quand on les poêle
quand quand on les rôtit mais après là
quand on les mélange à une base d'œuf de
lait et de farine ça ça ça donne des
goûts différents avec des aspects
différents avec des textures différentes
donc oui on est on est étonné et puis il
y en a qui vont plus se prêter à être
comme je disais en mise en bouche
c'est-à-dire en petite quantité d'autres
en entrée avec une salade d'autres avec
un un légume ou ou ou ou ou un féculant
donc il il y a énormément de façon donc
c'est pour ça que à chaque fois qu' pere
sucré aussi hein alors ça peut être
sucré le concours c'est basé
essentiellement sur du salé voà sur du
salé le Yolin voilà c décharge c'est
salé mais voilà mais à la maison après
on s'amuse à le faire sucrer si on le
souhaite mais bon ça c'est un autre on
verra peut-être un autre pour le
concours c'est salé pour le concours
c'est salé clair alors inscription je
disais 26 janvier 26 février pendant un
mois sur le site
leolf et et on a jusqu'à quand pour pour
envoyer la recette ben en fait le site
vient d'être ouvert et donc logiquement
c'est le 26 février mini où où
s'arrêtera la réception des faut donner
un TER ça veut dire quoi en terme de de
produits qu'on veut util dis il y a il y
a une saisonnalité évidemment voilà
alors c'est toute la difficulté de de
lancer un concours au mois de janvier
évidemment parce que si on respecte la
saabilité dans je veux dire dans les
ivelines HE et ben on n' pas de tomate
oui on n' pas de courgette on a' pas de
choses comme ça c'est là où on demande
aussi aux participants d'être créatifs
et de se projeter aussi de pas rester
uniquement dans ce qu'on a aujourd'hui
c'est-à-dire topinembourg dans les Blade
dans tout ça bien sûr d'c on a le droit
de mettre de l'utomate même si c'est pas
exactement la saison d'accord d'accord
mett poivon je sais que maintenant vous
êtes un chef très préoccupé hein par par
justement la saisonalité le le le le
fait de ce qu'on trouve pas pas très
loin de chez soi et cetera dans votre
restaurant mais là voilà on on peut être
plus
plus Saer si si pas du tout et c'est là
justement où quand on parlait de
créativité entre guillemets hein
c'est-à-dire que il faut se projeter
aussi que le liolin peut être mangé
toute l'année donc c'est ça c'est ça où
il faut aussi penser que asperg premers
légumes verts qui vont arriver bien
bientôt ben il faut penser aux asperges
ah oui on pourrait faire un Yolin aux
asperges c'est c'est là où où la
différence va se faire aussi dans la
sélection des reces c'est avec
l'originalité avec la projection sur les
différentes saisons voilà et puis comme
il y a comme il y a olympique dans et
puis voilà oui oui donc on peut
passenser au mois de mois de juillet
d'août ouais ouais non mais c'est sûr
donc il faut penser au aux herbes et aux
plantes aux légumes au légumes d'été
ouais bien sûr non mais je je demandis
ça pour que les Ch oui oui bien sr par
parfis on peut dire ah non vous avez pas
utilis un enfin un produit du moment et
non on a le droit voilà là on va être
sur un livre de recette qui va sortir au
mois de juin et qui est pour toute
l'année et c'est pour ça que c'est c'est
un livre alors on l'appelle pas livre de
cuisine parce que pour moi un livre de
cuisine c'est quelque chose où toutes
les recettes sont détaillées là on est
sur un livre de recette parce que comme
on en a parlé on mélange des œufs de la
farine et du lait et après on met ce
qu'on veut dedans donc c'est c'est un
livre où on va prendre des idées de
Yolin différents euh selon les recettes
qui auront gagné quoi absolument euh qu
je je reviens sur ce qu'on voit dans le
site justement c'est que oui on peut on
peut trouver tous les produits possibles
et imaginables dans dans les ivelines
oui oui mais même moi j'en découvre au
fur à mesure que que que j'avance que je
recherche oui bien sûr euh les les
derniers bon j'ai trouvé c'est les les
kiwi bon on est sur un fruit mais les
kiwi de de l'esly le le safran le safran
de la maison blanchée euh bon on a le
champignon de Paris hein avec les
carrières mais mais on a aussi de la
pleurotte par exemple donc à sa Nom la
Bretèche on a du tofu ça je viens de le
découvrir à la ferme des petits evoris à
alinville donc on a vraiment une
multitude de de de de produits de
producteurs il y a les bienfaisantes à
rembouiller là qui font un un un confit
de de de citron alors oui le citron
n'est pas n'est pas des hivblines il est
il est français il est français hein il
est français mais il est produit il est
fabriqué par une entreprise locale qui
fait marcher l'économie locale donc
c'est c'est ça qui est important c'est
de montrer tout ce qui se fait
riche après les boissons he je veux dire
ça va des jus de fruits en passant par
de la bière en allant jusqu'au vin avec
de l'eau je veux dire voilà il y a il a
il y a vraiment énormément de produit il
y a encore beaucoup à faire mais mais il
y a déjà énormément de produits j'étais
chez chez Christian la semaine dernière
euh avec qui je travaille énormément
puisque il a une multitude de de de de
céréales de légumineus c'est à Ben hein
donc et en fait il ils ont une grande
gamme de de légumineuses céral de
différents producteurs des ibelines en
fait ils se sont regroupés donc c'est ça
qui est génial quand on va chez eux
c'est l'huilerie de la plaine de
bersaill c'est que on a une multitude de
producteurs en fait en allant à un seul
endroit et et par exemple ben j'ai
appris j'en ai ramené on en train de
faire des essis à la maison il y a des
haricots blancs et des haricots rouges
qui arrivent euh sur notre territoire
donc voilà on va avoir des haricots
blancs des haricots rouges donc ça c'est
exceptionnel ça montre qu'il y a encore
énormément de choses à faire je parlais
du pavau je disais ben il y a pas de
pavau ah B non il y en a pas c'est vrai
ah bah oui c'est pourquoi pas voilà donc
on a encore plein de choses à faire quoi
donc c'est c'est ça qui n'hésitez pas à
aller sur le le site leyolin.fr vous
allez trouver bah toutes les adresses
possibles qui vont vous permettre de
vous procurer euhû les les les produits
dans dans les ivelines euh qu'est-ce
qu'il faut dire encore pour ben alors en
plus des lots à gagner de de en fait de
sa recette he il y a il y a une centaine
de l'au à gagner gag parce que vous avez
vous avez bah j'allais dire des des gens
qui vous partenair suération qui vous
aide en qui nous aide bien sûrin qui
nous aide surtout voilà pour donner
envie de participer je veux dire on est
on est chacun challengé par telle ou
telle chose donc voilà on a on a des des
des chèqus cadeau dans différents
restaurants des des ielines qui ont été
sympas sur ça sur tout le territoire on
a des bons d'achat dans des dans des
magasins Cultura dans des magasins
Leclerc à progourmet à Orgeval qui est
un indépendant qui fait du matériel de
cuisine mais qui qui nous qui nous
suit le réseau Territoria aussi qui nous
a offert des des des coffrets cadeaux
dans leur hôtel et restaurants donc
voilà on et et et et je le dis c'est que
ben on peut encore nous rejoindre en
tant que part partenaire voilà c'est
pour montrer que sur le territoire dans
le Yolin il y a un inclusif c'est que
tout le monde est dans le projet tout le
monde est inclu et on y va tous pour
promouvoir notre territoire et il faut
dire mais on y reviendra parce qu'on
voir l'occasion de revenir de manière
assez régulière sur sur la progression
de de l'opération qu'une une partie des
des des recettes du du livre voà seront
redonnés au resto du cœur voilà il y
aura 5 € le livre sera vendu 19,90 € et
il y aura 5 € qui seront reversé au
restaurant du cœur des ivines hein on
voulait que ça reste aussi local donc
c'est vu avec les restos du cœur donc
donc voilà l'aventure
seraavure commence et elle se finira et
bravo d'avoir d'avoir comment c'est venu
ben c'est venu c'est le constat après la
rider Cup de 2018 j'en parle souvent
avec des restaurateurs des acteurs
locaux et et en fait en 2018 on a eu la
rider Cup on savait que la rider Cup
arrivé on savait ce que c'était mais on
s'est pas préparé et en fait on a on a
eu des clients on a eu une bonne
ambiance mais on était pas prêt pas plus
que ça et et
donc je me suis dit une fois qu'on a su
avec les Jos il faut être prêt quoi et
c'est vrai qu'en tant que commerçant
petit commerçant on a toujours du mal à
se projeter et à dire B allez je me
prépare pour l'année prochaine qu'est-ce
que je peux faire qu'est-ce que jeux
faire donc voilà pourquoi je voulais
qu'il y ait un projet commun
euh et donc est venu l'idée du du Yolin
voilà et du plat et de l'identité
culinaire des Yvelines alors on va
rappeler euh les les deux trois choses
essentielles
l'appareil appareil simple UF farine
farine lait lait voilà à partir de là
vous rajoutez au moins au moins trois
produits qu'on peut trouver dans les
ivelines identifier des ivelines
c'estàdire qu'il nous faudra l'adresse
exacte tout ça et après aussi on peut
ajouter d'autres choses c'est-à-dire moi
je suis du Nord de la France si je veux
ajouter du maroal dedans j'ajouterai du
maroal un Normand peut ajouter
goter un peu de P ou un peu de trois
produits des evvelines au moins et après
le reste libre voilà si vous voulez
rajouter un peu de crème vous rajoutez
un peu de crème si voilà c'est c'est
vraiment libre à chacun alors on en a
pas parlé mais il faut pas oublier de
saler et de poivré et ça c'est et alors
euh une fois que la recette est faite
comment alors qui qui comment on fait
pour qui va goûter le jury alors on pose
souvent la question alors on n'est pas
dans les dans les concours de commune où
on apporte sa tarte aux pommes
chacunûte non là on est jugé par un vrai
un vrai jur de professionnel en fait he
et et nous les professionnels quand on
fait des concours de cuisine on on
sélectionne sur recette sur papier sur
bon d'conoma et et donc en lisant un bon
d'conoma des gens on voit déjà un si
c'est le sujet ou hors sujet
c'est-à-dire est-ce qu'il y aura déjà
trois produits des evvines identifiés
s'il y en a pas ben déjà c'est h sujet
et après il y a la recette les quantités
on demande pour quatre personnes donc si
vous mettez une recette pour 4 personnes
avec 5 L de lait et 24 ufs on se dira
pour qure ça fait un peu
beaucoup donc voilà il y a toujours ça
et puis après il y a l'alliance des
produits voilà quand on parle de
créativité il faut rester raisonnable
donc on a on a donc c'est un jugement
tout se passe au fond par Internet ouis
tout se passe par internet mais après
bon ben les juris vont se retrouver pour
pour discuter je pense qu'on va mettre
une bonne moi je ne suis pas jury il y a
aucun jury qui est des hiblines parce
que je voulais qu'on soit jugé par
d'autres personnes qui voilà qui sont
partenair ou qui font partie de
association et et donc on a Laurent
Petit TR étoiles à Hcy on a Christophe e
qui a deux étoiles à à Blois et qui sont
deux personnes aussi dans leur région
très investies dans dans alors plus que
le local quoi vraiment dans la recherche
du produit de la la terre de la défense
parce que local c'est c'est vague mais
et et puis après ben des partenaires
aussi euh comme C Tunk la secrétaire
générale du collège culinaire de France
voilà on a
des professionnel des vrais
professionnels qui connaissent ça et qui
savent aussi lire un bon économin mais
mais surtout en faisant ça c'est comme
ça ça permet aux gens de le faire de
chez eux et de ne
pas voilà tout se passe pour ça je dis
tout peut se passer par Internet ça va
très vite c'est très rapide et et bah
tout tous tout le monde au fourneau tous
en cuisine voilàine t en cuisine voilà
bon écoutez merci beaucoup euh Laurent
et et puis ce que je propose c'est qu'on
on se revoit régulièrement hein pour
pour voir bah comment ça se passe
l'opération on fera peut-être un point
en févrierès bien avec plaisir merci ok
merci beaucoup le et vive le Yolin vive
le
[Musique]
Yolin